do you have a concern of super
intelligent AGI
open sourced
and then what do you do with that I'm
not saying control it it's open source
what do we do with this human species if
that's not up to me I mean you know like
I'm not a central planner I'm not
Central planner but you'll probably
tweet there's a few days left to live
for the human species I have my ideas of
what to do with it and everyone else has
their ideas of what to do with it but
the best ideas win but at this point do
you brainstorm like
because it's not regulation it could be
decentralized regulation where people
agree that this is just like we create
tools that make it more difficult for
you
to uh
maybe make it more difficult for code to
spread you know antivirus software this
kind of thing but they're saying that
you should build AI firewalls that
sounds good you should definitely be
running an AI firewall yeah right you
should be running an AI firewall to your
mind right you're constantly under you
know such an interesting ideas Infowars
man like I don't know if you're being
sarcastic or no I'm dead serious but I
think there's power to that it's like
how do I
protect my mind from influence of
human-like or superhuman intelligent
Bots I have not being I would pay so
much money for that product I would pay
so much money for that product you know
how much money I'd pay just for a spam
filter that works
well on Twitter sometimes I
would like to have a
a uh a protection mechanism for my mind
from the outrage mobs yeah because they
feel like bot like Behavior it's like
yeah there's a large number of people
that will just grab a viral narrative
and attack anyone else that believes
otherwise and it's like whenever
someone's telling me some story from the
news I'm always like I don't want to
hear a CIA Opera it's a CIA Opera like
it doesn't matter if that's true or not
it's just trying to influence your mind
you're repeating an ad to me
with the viral mobs this is like they're
yeah they're like to me a defense
against those those mobs
is just getting multiple perspectives
always from
from sources that make you feel kind of
like you're getting smarter
and just actually just basically feels
good like a good documentary just feels
good something feels good about it it's
well done it's like oh okay I never
thought of it this way it just feels
good sometimes the outrage mobs even if
they have a good point behind it when
they're like mocking and derisive and
just aggressive you're with us or
against us this this [__] this is why
I delete my tweets
yeah why'd you do that
I was you know I was I missed your
tweets you know what it is the algorithm
promotes toxicity yeah
and like
you know I think Elon has a much better
chance of fixing it than the previous uh
regime
yeah but to solve this problem to solve
like to build a social network that is
actually not toxic without
moderation
like uh not the stick but carrots so
like what people uh look for goodness
so make it uh catalyze the process of
connecting cool people and being cool to
each other yeah without ever censoring
without ever censoring and and like
Scott Alexander has a blog post I like
where he talks about like moderation
it's not censorship right like all
moderation you want to put on Twitter
right like you could totally make this
moderation like just a you don't have to
block it for everybody you can just have
like a filter button right that people
can turn off if they was like say search
or Twitter right like someone could just
turn that off right so like but then
you'd like take this idea to an extreme
right well the network should just show
you
this is a Couchsurfing CEO thing right
if it shows you right now these
algorithms are designed to maximize
engagement Well turns out outrage
maximizes engagement Quirk of human
Quirk of the human mind all right just
as I fall forward Everyone Falls for it
um so yeah you gotta figure out how to
maximize for something other than
engagement and I actually believe that
you can make money with that too so it's
not I don't think engagement is the only
way to make money I actually think it's
incredible that we're starting to see I
think again elon's doing so much stuff
right with Twitter like charging people
money as soon as you charge people money
they're no longer the product
they're the customer
and then they can start building
something that's good for the customer
and not good for the other customer
which is the ad agencies as an as in
picked up steam
I pay for Twitter doesn't even get me
anything it's my donation to this new
business model hopefully working out
sure but you know you for this business
model to work it's like most people
should be signed up to Twitter and so
the way it was
there was something perhaps not
compelling or something like this to
people I think you need most people at
all I think that why do I need most
people right I don't make an 8 000
person company make a 50-person company